ja und ein Ziel der russischen Offensive
ist offenbar eben auch die 300.000
Einwohner Stadt cernyhift die im Norden
der Ukraine an der Grenze zu Belarus
liegt hier befindet sich nämlich das
sogenannte operative Armee Kommando Nord
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte ein Video
soll hier nun den Abschuss eines
russischen Kampfjets zeigen
Abschuss über der Ukraine dieses Video
veröffentlichen die ukrainischen
Behörden am Samstag es soll einen
russischen Kampfjet zeigen der in der
Nähe von czernichi zu Boden geht
weitere Aufnahmen sollen die
Löscharbeiten nach dem Absturz zeigen
weiter werden Wohnhäuser beschossen wie
hier in bella-zergwar in der Nähe von
Kiew ein Video der Polizei zeigt das
Ausmaß der Zerstörung
am Samstagmorgen soll es eigentlich eine
Waffenruhe in Mario Pohl geben fünf
Stunden Zeit für die Bewohner die Stadt
zu verlassen doch schon kurz nach der
Verkündung wieder Schüssel die Menschen
müssen zurück in die Schutzräume am
Samstagnachmittag setzt das russische
Militär nach eigenen Angaben die
Angriffe auf Mario Pohl Ford
laut die Menschenrechts Büro der
Vereinten Nationen gibt es bisher
aufgrund der Kämpfe in der Ukraine
mindestens 351 bestätigte Todesfälle
unter Zivilisten die tatsächlichen
Zahlen sein wahrscheinlich viel höher
die meisten Opfer wurden demnach bei
Explosionen von Granaten und Raketen
oder bei Luftangriffen getötet
tausende Flüchtlinge die es aus der
Ukraine rausgeschafft haben kommen
unterdessen in Berlin an wann Sie wieder
zurück in ihre Heimat können ist
ungewiss denn Putins Angriff geht
gnadenlos weiter
das wollen wir natürlich besprechen und
einschätzen bei mir im Studio ist
Bildreporter Björn Stritzel also Björn
wir haben eben gesehen Kampfjets über
Wohngebieten im tieflug sozusagen wie
schätzt du das ganze ein also dass die
im tieflug Fliegen das hat den Grund
dass eben
Putins Armee immer noch nicht die
Lufthoheit hat das heißt dass sie
versuchen da dem dem feindlichen Radar
sozusagen zu entgehen dass sie über
Wohngebieten sind entspricht dieser
Strategie die die russischen
Streitkräfte zunehmend an zunehmend
einsetzen die wir auch in Syrien gesehen
haben auch in Tschetschenien gesehen
haben
Wohngebiete die sie selber nicht erobern
können unbewohnbar zu machen also
tatsächlich ja so schwer zu bombardieren
das wird niemand mehr leben kann es ist
ja gerade gesehen haben ein su-34 also
in ein Bomber der russischen russischen
Luftwaffe der dann abgeschossen wurde
wir haben es ganz am Anfang ich weiß
nicht ob man es sehen kann der wirft
noch Täuschkörper ab wird aber dennoch
abgeschlossen was darauf hindeutet dass
die Waffe mit der abgeschossen wurde ein
neueres Modell ist für alle die sich
nicht so auskenntäuscht Körper das soll
ablenken sozusagen und die Raketen dann
in der anderen Richtung
Selbstverteidigungssystem sozusagen der
eines eines Luftfahrzeugs das zum
Beispiel ja Täuschkörper abwirft die ein
starkes infrarotssignal und ein starkes
werden Signal absenden und dann
sozusagen ein ankommende Rakete damit
abzulenken vom eigentlichen Ziel diese
diese Luftabwehr war für die die
Luftabwehrrakete die den Jet dennoch
getroffen hat ist mutmaßlich
wahrscheinlich eine neuere stingerrakete
die sofort drei vier Jahren umfassende
Modernisierung erfahren haben und dann
auch sozusagen unterscheiden können
zwischen solchen täuschkörpern und dem
eigentlichen Ziel interessant ist aber
dennoch dass sozusagen in den sozialen
Medien und auch in der in den Bildern
die die ukrainische Streitkräfte selber
veröffentlichen gar nicht die Rede von
den stingern ist sondern werden dann
immer ältere Modelle russische Modelle
die ukrainische Armee auch hat also zum
Beispiel diese e-klar bzw eine polnische
Version davon gezeigt das kann muss
nicht unbedingt heißen ist tatsächlich
eine solche Waffe zum Einsatz gekommen
ist sondern dass man sich vielleicht
auch darauf verständigt hat dass man
nicht unbedingt die Stinger zeigen
möchte beim Abschluss eines russischen
Flugzeugs damit sozusagen auch gewisse
Dinge noch geheim bleiben was könnte der
Hintergrund sein also zum einen
vielleicht dass das sozusagen genau
tatsächlich geheim bleibt wo die
eingesetzt werden wann die eingesetzt
werden wie sie eingesetzt werden zum
anderen vielleicht war aber auch eine
der bitten sozusagen vielleicht der
deutschen Regierung dass man gesagt hat
wir möchten nicht unbedingt das ist
jetzt groß in auf Videos veröffentlicht
wird wie die deutsche Waffen russische
Flugzeuge abschießen wir wollen
gemeinsam noch mal auf ein weiteres
Video schauen was uns gestern erreicht
hat da da soll ein russischer Helikopter
von einer ukrainischen Luftabwehrrakete
getroffen worden sein wir sehen es jetzt
hier genau am Ende geht dann dieser
Helikopter in einem Feuerball auf diese
Aufnahmen die kursieren bei Social Media
auch ist hier in N hatte darüber
berichtet kannst du das ein bisschen
einordnen für uns
also ist auch ein ein russischer
Kampfhubschrauber an wie 35 glaube ich
und der wird ja wird da quasi auch
sehr effektiv bekämpft hat natürlich
auch keine Chance dort im tieflug aber
du hältst die Bilder durchaus für echt
also die sind meiner festen Überzeugung
dafür echt also da gibt es auch
korrespondierende Bilder von von
fragteilen von ja also auch aus eurem
nicht nur diese einzelne Aufnahme anhand
der man das dann verifizieren kann genau
also es ist durchaus echt und auch das
belegt eben noch mal dass die dass die
russische Armee weiter von entfernt ist
da die Lufthoheit zu haben das ist und
es zeigt eben auch die Effektivität
solcher solcher schultergestützte
luftabwehrwaffen
genau haben uns noch weitere Bilder
erreicht unter anderem von einem liegen
gebliebenen russischen Konvoi da sehen
wir dann eine ukrainische Soldaten die
darum herumlaufen und sich das Ganze
anschauen erklär uns mal was genau da
passiert sein könnte was wir da genau
auch sehen was das alles dafür Material
ist was da am Boden liegt
liegen geblieben hast du schon gesagt
genau also der man könnte vermuten der
sei vielleicht im Schnee aber es ist
zumindest wenn man sich die die den
Schaden an den Fahrzeugen anschaut
wahrscheinlich kein Luftschlag gewesen
ist eigentlich nur das Führungsfahrzeug
was man glaube ich irgendwann vielleicht
auch noch mal ein Video oder am Anfang
sieht was tatsächlich schwer getroffen
wurde wahrscheinlich von einer auch von
der Panzerabwehrwaffe und ansonsten
scheint es mir aber eher zu sein dass es
das ist dass dieser Convoi das Leute aus
diesem konvoir geflohen sind bzw unter
ja und in so einem Hinterhalt geraten
sind interessant ist dann noch die die
Ausrüstung die wir da gesehen haben ich
weiß nicht ob man es sehen konnte in dem
einen war kurz zu sehen im unter anderem
Schild in das was was Polizisten
einsetzen das heißt genau das war ein
Konvoi sozusagen der rasquartier also
der der russischen Nationalgarde die dem
Innenministerium eigentlich unterstellt
sind und die eigentlich dafür da sind ja
nicht ein Kampf gegen eine bewaffnete an
mir zu führen sondern so Aufstände
Grenzschutz und so weiter
kann sondern sozusagen tatsächlich eher
ja demonstrieren Demonstration
niederzuprügeln solche Sachen und ja mit
unterhalten auch Grenzschutz und so
weiter aber das ist eben kein Konvoi den
man also keine Einheiten die man
einsetzt im Kampf gegen gegen eine
feindliche Armee und das zeigt auch so
ein bisschen die die geringe
Flexibilität der russischen Streitkräfte
die im 10.11 Tag des Krieges immer noch
solche Einheiten reinstecken am Anfang
haben sie dir auch schon reingeschickt
solche leicht bewaffneten Einheiten die
eigentlich nur dafür da sind eine
Bevölkerung zu kontrollieren wurden dann
komplett aufgerieben und 10 Tage später
sind sie nicht in der Lage des sozusagen
zu tauschen sondern schicken da immer
noch solche Einheiten rein und werden
dann halt von ukrainischen Hinterhalten
ja gerade in ukrainische Hinterhalt und
werden da schwer aufgeregt
dürfte nicht im Interesse von Wladimir
Putin sein wie dieser Teil seiner
Kriegsführung läuft dankeschön für deine
ganz aktuelle Einschätzung dazu